face blight companies face x will try to
make history tonight for the first time
it will reuse a rocket that's been to
space and back again for not all of the
companies more than 30 missions with the
Falcon 9 rocket have been successful two
rockets exploded costing SpaceX tens of
millions of dollars Manuel Bojorquez is
at Kennedy Space Center in Florida with
the high stakes of this launch man well
good morning good morning from this
spectacular site were just about 400
yards away from the launch pad
you know Rockets can cost hundreds of
millions of dollars and practically all
of them are either destroyed or not
recovered after launch but this one
right here is different it's been to
space before reusable rockets are vital
to the SpaceX mission of cheaper more
economic space travel liftoff of the
Falcon 9 rocket it may be a used rocket
but SpaceX is hoping this Falcon 9 will
help the company soar into new territory
the mission could advance SpaceX's goal
of bringing down launch costs and
eventually sending humans to Mars they
call it a previous flown or flight
proven rocket but it's a huge rocket so
it's going to be pretty interesting if
you can lower the cost for your
usability and other such measures your
open space up to more people last April
the Falcon 9 successfully landed on an
unmanned drone ship before crews hauled
it back to Florida to be cleaned up and
refurbished this time it will carry a
communication satellite into orbit for
luxembourg-based satellite company SES
is there a risk involved in something
that is still experimental no it's not
really experimental we understand
exactly all the testing that's taking
place a design what this being tasted in
place and that allows us to mitigate the
risk we're convinced this is a good
booster
although the rocket landed back on Earth
about a year ago SpaceX says it can turn
them around for relaunch in about four
months the goal is to make that even
faster as far as doing it as soon as you
land taking it over to the launch pad
and re flying it again we might be a
couple of years away from that but
that's certainly the intent
the landings can be as dramatic as the
liftoffs sometimes on land but often on
a small floating landing path SpaceX has
stuck the landing 8 out of 13 times this
is a very big deal if they can pull it
off but pulling off this mission is just
one step SpaceX has to demonstrate they
can do this routinely and do it reliably
so that customers out there will have
confidence to put their very expensive
satellites on top of a used rocket and
while this Rockets trip could be
historic it will also be a short one
just about eight to nine minutes between
launch and landing Gale all right Thank
You Man well